[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous on attend vos points de vue
c'est figaro live on attend surtout ce
soir vos hommages vos hommages
éventuelles est-ce que vous rendez
hommage au prince philippe qui vient de
décéder dont on a annoncé le décès se
battent à sa mort et l anecdotique pour
vous ou bien est ce un symbole un
symbole important on attend vos
réactions vos éventuels hommage
on attend également les réactions ce
soir de laurent joffrin
bonsoir adorent un leader d engager
anciens direct les désengager de
libération également aucun mot parfois
on a avec les grands esprits il y en a 2
ce soir
et bien sûr tous les internautes qui
nous regardent vous êtes ancien
directeur donc de libération et auteur
d'anti macron lettres politiques qui
sont édités chez stock
on attend aussi la réaction de jean
christophe buisson directeur adjoint du
figaro magazine
or une du fig mag ce week-end l'alertent
lancé sur la révolution racialiste en
cours a vertement c'est à la fois par
notre consoeur de ces news et d'europe 1
sonia mabrouk et et par mathieu bock
côté qui vient d'écrire ce livre la
révolution racialiste et autres virus
idéologique et c'est aux éditions de la
cité alors oui ces presses de la cité en
fait parce que là je n'ai que la
collection oui effectivement la cité aux
éditions presses de la cité
excellente relation ils ont 2 jean
christophe buisson bon effectivement
vous avez supervisé donc l'interview et
avec alexandre ii vecchio donc évitons
donc effectivement vous n'aviez pas
beaucoup de mérite dans ce domaine mais
quand même on le signale vous fusille
également dans
le figmag ce week-end et
ce morceau des morceaux choisis d'un
livre qu'on imaginait exceptionnel le
vatican nid d'espions qui écrit par l'un
des meilleurs spécialistes sur la
question qui est yvonnick denoël
on reviendra aussi pendant cette
émission sur l'annulation du voyage de
jean castex en algérie et sur les gardés
à vue en série dans la crise sanitaire
c'est un festival
cette semaine ce matin pierre jean
chalencon et son chef cuisinier et puis
deux prêtres du diocèse de paris hier
alors est ce justifié s disproportionnée
on en débat le chef cuisinier c'est
christophe leroy
mais d'abord cet hommage qui a été rendu
tout à l'heure par boris johnson on se
souviendra du désamour pour tout ce
qu'il a fait notamment toujours son
soutien auprès de la magie c'est la
reine il était à ses côtés pendant
chacun des jours de son règne en tant
que et ponts du sturm a de ce fait à sa
majesté et à toute sa famille que toute
la grande bretagne pense aujourd'hui
alors le prince philippe aurait eu 100
ans le 10 juin prochain et ce soir c'est
un comble sur ce plateau puisque nous
avons deux admirateur de napoléon pour
commenter la mort d'un prince anglais
alors que justement des milliers de
britanniques se pressent devant windsor
et buckingham pour rendre leurs hommages
déposé leurs fleurs prononcer leurs
prières sur twitter jean christophe vous
vous en prenez à ceux qui présentent le
prince comme un aristocrate
condescendant ayant fait preuve de
racisme
impérial en l'occurrence au journal le
monde qui résume la vie de duc
d'edimbourg à 7 assez caractéristique et
c'est profondément évidemment réducteur
et injuste pour ne pas dire plus parce
que ce qui est admirable dans la vie il
me semble de ceux de cet homme c'est le
l'esprit de sacrifice qu'il a animée
d'abord c'est un héros de la seconde
guerre mondiale ne faut pas l'oublier et
ensuite c'est quelqu'un qui en épousant
les abbés de à renoncer à sa nationalité
à sa foi orthodoxe à ses titres de
noblesse et accepter l'idée que toute sa
vie il serait en retrait il serait dans
l'ombre
on parle souvent de des hommes de la
société masculinise qui maintient les
femmes dans l'eau glacée exactement
contraire qui s'est passé
et toute la vie tout sa vie il est resté
comme ça ne veut pas de pas de compter
et on a compris que l'idée monarchique
c'est pas un roi ou une reine qui règne
chez une famille c'est une famille
royale qui est qui qui symbolise qui
incarne la continuité historique d'une
nation et parfois
constitutionnel s'était pas le camp
monarchie puisque c'est une monarchie
constitutionnelle donc c'est pas c'est
pas évidemment les le roi ou la reine
qui gouvernent mais mais qui symbolique
la continuité de l'histoire de ce pays
et lui n'a jamais fait un pas de un pas
de trop un pas de un pas de côté un pas
de travers il s'est maintenu toute sa
vie c'est d'une manière ça se trouve ça
exemplaire de considérer que sa vie va
être va être dédiée à un la femme qu'on
aime ou à l'homme qu'on aime et deux à
son pays au risque de soi même de ne pas
pouvoir faire grand chose ça c'est une
véritable une véritable mission donc je
trouve ça assez admirable et comme on
est quand même une époque on cherche des
exemples des modèles
je trouve que réfléchir quelques minutes
sur ce qu'ils qu'il incarne comme modèle
c'est intéressant et par ailleurs
n'oublions pas que c'est un homme qui a
quand même un petit peu modernisée dans
le bon sens du terme la monarchie
anglaise qui lui a fait prendre son
virage un petit peu au collège
écologistes dans les années 70 ce qui a
un peu d rigidifier cette monarchie qui
est quand même très installé qui est qui
a secoué un petit peu il avait deux qui
qu'il a volontiers accepté parce
qu'elle-même ne manque pas d'humour
alors parfois il a fait deux événements
des blacks qui ne passent plus
aujourd'hui mais je crois qu'il a
vraiment été important dans la dans la
dans la stabilité et la longévité de
elizabeth 2 qui fêtera ses 95 ans
malheureusement un petit peu en deuil
la semaine prochaine si je m'abuse le 21
avril à l'euro à 95 ans laurent joffrin
ce que vous partagez le
pour être vue de jean christophe caffet
ou encore par partagez pas par exemple
le point de vue de gabriel cluzel qui
doué avec le principe c'est la couronne
d'angleterre comme on l'aimé qui s'en va
avant ça pipolisation ses états d'âme de
pauvre petite fille riche et pourtant
être le prince consort qui marche
toujours deux pas derrière darren
demandé de l'humilité pour le progrès ce
qu'est ce que vous êtes je vais bien
salué les sacrifices et j'ai le plus
grand respect pour la monarchie
britannique
assurer la continuité c'est vrai mais
qui a eu un comportement exemplaire
pendant la guerre par exemple mais il ya
des sacrifices quand même plus plus dur
que ça que de passer sa vie dans la
château à ne rien faire il entend bien
que c'est un sacrifice formidable mais
quand même un jeu j'ai du mal à autant
c'est un jour de deuil dans une faute
respectueux mais alors sur la vie passée
et mal à ça me tire pas des larmes en
plus alors vous me direz ce que je vais
dire à compter ça parce que ma source
principale c'est quand même la série de
kram
parce que je suis pas un grand lecteur
de ce qui se passe à buckingham palace
où on va balmoral mais quand on regarde
au crâne et c'est une série qui est
largement fait sur le était le
personnage est pas du tout sympathique
et alors c'est vrai qu'il a modernisé si
j'ai bien compris il a modernisé la
monarchie et deuxièmement il a soutenu
la reine donc c'est très bien
en revanche son attitude par exemple au
moment de la crise consécutive à la mort
de la princesse diana était à une
attitude même très durs ceux qui sèment
un don fait tout ce foin pour cette
fille qui ne vaut rien et a passé un peu
ce qu'il disait ce qu'il pensait
manifestement donc le personnage ambigu
mais moi je trouve qu'un incarner ce
n'est pas rien il ya effectivement des
fonctions où on travaille moins que
d'autres on en met une forme de 2,2 de
travail d'occupation de fonctions occupe
une fonction un pare-feu lève la
fonction est supérieur d'ailleurs c'est
ce qui est frappant dans la monarchie
britannique c'est que là aussi la voix
dans la série mais on le voit dans
dans la vie dans l'actualité le c'est
une monarchie fragile c'est ça qui est
le plus frappé dans cette histoire ils
ont toujours peur de devenir impopulaire
donc c'est une monarchie de droit divin
enfin de séculaire qui marche par
succession c'est donc normal non ils
sont là pour toujours
ils ont peur de certains peuples ils ont
peur de l'opinion ils sont obligés de
faire très attention au moindre geste
ils sont obligés de calculer les choses
mais je voudrais qu'il ya un écart et
c'est une c'est horrible il faut faire
autre chose je sois pas des faces en
fonction de l'opinion ils font ça en
fonction de ce qu'ils estiment être la
tradition la règle qui ceux qui
s'adaptent qui se modernise un fils à
papa mais qui s'adapte pas parce que
l'opinion dit lis vos pensées comme ci
ou comme ça manger de la viande ou pas
manger la viande qui s'adapte en
fonction de ce qu'ils estiment être le
devoir pour maintenir la monarchie dans
une forme à la fois traditionnels mais
adapté au niveau les en lui plus
politique que ça c'est à dire ils n'ont
pas le pouvoir mais ils ont le symbole
en politique souvent on a les deux en
france par exemple présente dans le
public est à la fois un symbole et un
homme de décision
il est obligé de tenir compte de
l'opinion la la c'est la politique coupé
en deux il ya que le symbole mais on
revient que le symbole est essentiel
parce que si jamais ils font des bêtises
il risque d'être d'être on l'a bien vu
dans les années 30 oui mais par exemple
regarder quand il avait 2 fait un
discours avec un petit chapeau aux
couleurs de l'europe en amérique site
c'est un acte très politique elle sait
très bien que la popularité qui est la
sienne elle s'en sert pour dire aux
anglais c'est une erreur de quitter
l'autre c'est vrai c'est un geste très
fort donc il est là c'est la reine oui
c'est l'autre cubique ils sont
indissociables
je crois que les habitants n'auraient
pas été ce qu'elle était sans volant
philippe sans le prince philip wee un
hommage justifié nous dit
liao belle qui donc rend ainsi son
hommage au prince au prince philip
bien entendu vous avez sur le site du
figaro toutes les informations ça vous
le voyez pas ce que c'est juste au
dessus de ce player
si vous êtes sur le site du figaro et
bien entendu dans le chat ou vincent est
en train de vous mettre toutes les
informations tout ce qu'il faut savoir
notamment sur les funérailles du prince
philippe est également marion galles
iramuno qui retrace la vie de ce prince
pour figaro live
nichols en profite pour décocher une
flèche c'est sûr que ma compte tient
compte de l'opinion
quel symbole notre président ce dont
convient aux questions nationales les ça
plaira nipple je pense à laurent joffrin
qui a écrit je vous le rappelle un livre
qui s'appelle anti macron jean castex
c'est plutôt de lui dont on va parler
soir devait se rendre à alger ce
week-end la visite est annulée alors
toute la question est de savoir pourquoi
côté français on invoque la crise
sanitaire
côté algérien il y a une autre version
qui en tout cas une source syndicale à
l'agencé france presse que
en fait la visite qui était prévu par
jean castex a été réduite à une seule
journée et la délégation à quatre
ministres or c'est pas du goût des
algériens qui vous qui trouve que
c'était un sous format alors qu'il y
avait beaucoup de dossiers bilatéraux a
étudié en clair les algériens trouvé
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de ministre
pour cette visite
il n'en voulait donc pas et apparemment
laurent joffrin jean castex a cédé ses
réseaux
c'est difficile de venir si on n'est pas
vraiment désiré conclut stéphane surtout
en diplomatie
je vois qu'il ya une autre raison j'ai
lu ça dans un papier c'est que il ya une
délégation dans marche qui avait ouvert
une espèce de club je crois au sahara
occidental qui est une pomme de discorde
très longtemps entre le nom qu'est
l'algérie et que donc cette espèce de
reconnaissance implicite par le parti du
président était très mal vue par les
autorités algériennes qu'on peut
comprendre mais c'est vrai aussi l
inverse que les militaires algériens
puisque la médiature font profession de
dire du mal de la france tout propos
parce que ça leur permet de se
relégitimer ils ont beaucoup de
difficultés avec leur peuple et les
élections sont pas vraiment libre la
liberté d'expression est quand même très
limités et donc ils se servent d'eux
du souvenir de la colonisation pour
toujours et nous on défend de la mémoire
algérienne la nation algérienne et serra
et la france il y en a un qui est un des
ministres algérien et du travail qui
viennent dire la france sera toujours
notre ennemi une ennemi traditionnel
éternel éternelle
mais internet comme le faire je
comprends par ailleurs là je prend le
manche en désaccord et beaucoup de gens
peut-être parmi les gens qui nous
écoutent d'ailleurs je comprends que la
france fasse des efforts pour sinon
s'excuser en tout cas reconnaître les
crimes de la colonisation qui sont
évidents et qui sont très très profond
et la conquête le maintien d'un ordre
injuste et puis tout ce qui s'est passé
après la guerre jusqu'à la jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'indépendance
la france porte une pas une part de
responsabilité lourde elle doit le
reconnaître c'est normal elle ne cesse
de le reconnaître en laurent joffrin ce
n'est jamais assez
non pas plus ou moins ils vous êtes bien
placé pour savoir puisque jacques chirac
voulait faire un traité d'amitié avec
l'algérie mais on lui demandait de faire
repentance repentance vraiment vos
trente ans ce qu'il a refusé
nicolas sarkozy était allé en algérie
lors d'un voyage même façon il avait dit
que la colonisation était injuste mais
ça n'était pas assez
françois hollande vous en souvenez lui
même on est considéré que c'était passé
alors qu'il y avait même dit que par
exemple sharon c'était un acte
scandaleux
enfin plus que ce qu'on a le criminel on
avait on avait réprimé le désir bien
naturel des algériens à l'indépendance
ça n'était pas assez aimée le maquereau
a parlé de crime contre l'humanité
ça n'est pas ça n'est jamais assez c'est
ça le froid jeudi au début c'est qu'ils
servent de ça pour se maintenir
mais ces militaires oui mais quand vous
dites la france ne reconnaît pas c'est
moi je vous dis que on essaie de le
faire
on ne cesse de le faire que ce soit au
niveau gouvernemental au niveau de la
mémoire avec le rapport de benjamin
stora qui oui et non parce que vous
étiez obligés de faire le rapport stora
pour aller un peu plus loin et ben ce
n'est pas assez pour quoi parce qu'on
demande aussi que puisqu'on met les
archives allait le faire moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord pour qu'il y ait du
travail des travaux historiques mais des
deux côtés
c'est à dire que ravir
citer le travail historique remarquable
qui a été fait par notre confrère jean
sevilla qui s'appelle les vérités
cachées de la guerre d'algérie qui vient
de sortir en poche d'ailleurs maintenant
sorti en poche les élites et regardez
par exemple en algérie on continue à
dire qu'il ya eu entre 1 million et un
million cinq cent mille victimes et ce
qui est faux ce qui est trois quatre
cinq fois plus qu'il y avait 300 mille
combattants flnc ya dû avoir cent mille
dont la moitié ont survécu il cent mille
civils
donc tant que corps officiels algériens
qui est qui et qui t'aime qui est
mythologique en partie c'est vrai ben
oui mais un exemple comment voulez vous
dire que c'était aussi une guerre civile
la guerre d'indépendance il y avait
plusieurs bien sûr à l'intérieur il ya
oussama y avait un aspect religieux
quelle honte aux ateliers le système est
bien vivante où les partisans réprimée
sur une falaise de manière honteuse bien
sûr les annonces majeures instaura
d'ailleurs pas qui à l'époque était trop
ce qu'ils comme messali hadj et kiwi sa
thèse absolument mais est-ce que ce que
je veux dire c'est que le il faut voir
aussi le contexte à dire que en ce
moment il ya un conflit un énième
conflit outre celui que vous avez évoqué
avec le sahara occidental qui est sur
les sites nucléaires qui n'ont pas été
décontaminés et l'algérie exige que la
france d'ailleurs un voyage du général
lecointe en algérie l'absolu d'échanger
un échange avec les militaires
les militaires algériens en dix ans
maintenant c'est à la france d'être
décontaminés donc on est dans un
contexte qui est un peu hostile avec
c'est avec cette affaire là avec la
sphère que vous citez avec peut-être
vous lirez dans le figaro demain des
révélations de christophe cornevin sur
les moines de tibérine avec une nouvelle
déclaration de quelqu'un qui pense que
c'est effectivement les services
algériens qui ont commis l'irréparable
tout ça fait une ambiance qui n'est pas
favorable et à chaque fois qu'il ya eu
un voyage d'un chef d'état en algérie ou
d'un gouvernement en algérie c'est
toujours mal ça toujours mal fini c'est
à dire à chaque fois au retour il ya une
polémique dans un sens ou dans l'autre
camp macron dit c'est un crime contre
l'humanité en lui et on lui reproche
quand certains là c'est pas les adjoints
c'est les français qui vont reprocher
macron d'être trop d'être allé trop loin
quand d'autres fois c'est les indiens
qui reprochent aux français de ne pas
s'être excusé et donc contexte est
favorable c'est pas le moment donc
peut-être que la raison sanitaire et j
ça se trouve on se trompe on discute du
puits diminuent de quelque chose qui
n'existe pas mais ça ne m'étonnerait pas
que me croire jean castex taille poids
va pas voulu y aller parce qu'il savait
qu'il en sortirait une polémique d'une
manière ou d'une autre
nicole 062 dit peu importe la raison il
faut arrêter de s'aplatir devant les
algériens vu la réflexion du ministre il
dit je suis fier de me passer des
visites qui s'est pas à plat dit
pourtant il ya une autre il peut ya une
autre lecture du de de cette annulation
de voyage c'est que finalement en
refusant de ce voyage il s'est plié aux
exigences algérienne qui voulait qu'il y
aurait plus de ministres qui viennent
dans ce cas ils seraient payés il avait
envoyé plus de 1000 mais si une fille
décide de pas venir ce qu'on peut pas
dire que ce soit une reddition ou dans
le clan c'est eux qui lie c'est pas la
peine de venir si vous ne venez pas au
complet donc
c'est la réponse de castex il se plie et
de fait à la volonté algérienne
après il y aurait pas pu arriver deux
forces avec seulement quelques souvenirs
donc on va pas recommencer un nom ce qui
est tragique c'est effectivement je
pense qu'il ya des efforts à faire des
deux côtés d'un point de vue de la
mémoire et de l'histoire je crois que
les français en font beaucoup mais tant
que les algériens ne veulent pas
admettre l'idée qu'il y a eu comme une
histoire commune entre 1830 et 1962
qu'il n'a pas été qu'une guerre de
domination de dominants et dominés de
coloniser de colonisateurs d'afrique aux
éditeurs qui a eu des soucis par contre
il peut y avoir une histoire commune
c'est l'histoire d'une domination mais
ce n'est pas qu'une histoire de
l'humiliation c'est ça que je voudrais
non c'est toi qui chantes domination
elle vient comment léon et l ordre
colonial pas possible oui mais vous
qu'on vous donnez l'impression qu'il y
avait que que deux catégories de
population au sein des européens il n'y
avait pas que des que de riches colons
il y avait aussi un visuel un petit
peuple
1 au sein des arcades 0.0 étaient pas
tous français d alger n y avait pas que
des algériens il aussi des cabines vous
savez très bien où il veut ou tribus et
cetera qui n'est d'accord ne dépendent
pas et donc on fait comme si ses
pendants l'os à l'exode l'un des
fondateurs du fln a fait la guerre on
est française il rentre en algérie donc
en 45 et y postule pour être garde
champêtre il était officier dans l'armée
française les gardes champêtres
ça a été refusé par les colons parce que
comme un prétexte le vague il est entré
dans le mouvement indépendantiste c'est
ça la réalité de la vie quotidienne en
algérie ces bruits mais ce n'est pas que
ça je vais vous dire je dis ça en
l'occurrence tout ce qui était positif
est systématiquement goomany on vous
pose une question sur twitter jean
castex at il eu raison d'annuler sa
visite en algérie alors je ne sais pas
on va peut-être voir la réponse à la
question twitter il paraît que ça arrive
on peut parier sur les sur les
pourcentages effectivement juste avant
le début de l'émission je vous donne un
indice
la réponse était plutôt positive 72% 72%
et c'est pas c'est pas encore c'est pour
accor arriver si ça y est c'est mon
bilan est effectivement vous avez perdu
mon cher ami de loi mais c'était 82 pour
ça
ce que j'avais le dos just et de ne pas
de ne pas céder
cet internaute nous dit les crimes ont
été atroces et autres aussi vrai
cependant il est un peu curieux pour ne
pas dire autrement il ne faut pas dire
il ne faudrait pas trop en faire mc on
doit s'excuser encore nous dise est
intervenue alors c'est pas la vie de
quelqu'un qui s'est exprimé ce matin
philippe de villiers à l'occasion
d'ailleurs d'un nouveau livre sur la
crise sanitaire
j'ai une surprise
mais je vais rappeler à ce moment là une
phrase terrible que il faudra qu'ils
regrettent un jour devant tous les
français là la colonisation est un crime
contre l'humanité un chef d'état qui dit
ça je pense qu'il peut pas se
représenter
celle-ci nossik le côté français aussi
la plaie est encore vive oui mais il ya
toujours des gens qui vont vous
expliquer que la colonisation c'était
pas si mal mais ils se trompent ils se
trompent tout ça et c'est une longue
histoire
tout ce qu'on veut mais et aux global
ise mais tu veut baliser globalement
c'était une heure mais vous dire c'était
pas si mal si on prend des points précis
puisque tout à l'heure vous avez
prenez-en précis on va parler les
hôpitaux on va parler des routes en aval
et ça c'était pas si mal
on peut pas dire que c'était mal de
faire des routes de faire d'eux de
permettre à la mission d'arrêter de
mourir je dis que globalement brillé
mais si vous vous dites que l'on peut
pas dire que c'est m6 par par endroits
c'était bien par moments c'était bien
par par zone s'était bien par secteur
c'est des bénéficiaires des nominations
aux permanents n'est pas permanent c'est
dans ce couvent globalisé trop enduré le
débat peut continuer alors pour nourrir
le débat
l'année prochaine il ya plein
d'anniversaire les accords d'evian
l'indépendance de l'algérie donc on en
refera effectivement dans tous les cas
d'abord il ya un dossier à retrouver
dans le
dans le figaro dans l'édition papier
dans les prochaines heures et dans
l'édition datée de ce samedi et puis de
livres à lire pour poursuivre le débat
indispensable
on a parlé de ce que jean sévillia
l'autre livre c'est celui nos confrère
christophe dubois et marie christine
tabet qui s'intitule paris alger une
histoire passionnelle c'est le livre à
lire sur les relations franco
algériennes et qui explique de façon
très claire et très dépassionner ce qui
est extrêmement rare dans un an sur
cette question là les différents aspects
de cette relation
on n'a pas encore parlé de coronavirus
sénat si les internautes en parle parce
qu'ils nous disent à propos de jean
castex sur les raison d'annuler le
voyage en algérie françois il doit
montrer c'est sur youtube
il doit montrer l'exemple en ne voyant
jean pas nous ronger notre frein avec
les 10 km qu'ils fassent de même c'est à
dire aussi quand même que la question
est quand même là aussi assez vives pour
chez nos internautes
alors cette semaine on n'a pas tellement
progressé sur la question des créations
de places en réanimation sur l'arrivage
des vaccins ouvert dès vaccinodromes on
est revenu sur cette question en début
de semaine la question est en réalité
beaucoup ailleurs si on consulte les
réseaux sociaux le hashtag qui a
cartonné sait on veut les noms les noms
des ministres qui auraient dîné avec le
collectionneur pierre jean chalon sont
alors il a beau avoir démenti la
polémique continue et elle indigne les
membres du gouvernement comme bruno le
maire je trouve toute cette histoire
dangereuse pour le démocratie est
révoltante
calomniez calomniez il en restera
toujours quelque chose
c'est trop facile ce cynisme c'est trop
facile de jeter des noms en pâture
c'est trop facile de jouer sur leurs
sentiments les personnes qui jouent avec
sa doivent être dénoncés et si elles ont
procédé par mensonge par allusion
mensongère poursuivi et condamné une
démocratie repose sur la vérité
alors depuis pierre-jean chalencon et le
chef cuisinier christophe leroy sont en
garde à vue ils sont soupçonnés d'être
les maîtres d'oeuvre c'est dîner privé
avec plus de six convives sans masque
sans distanciation sociale des dîners
filmé en caméra cachée par nos confrères
de m6 et qui ont circulé sur les réseaux
sociaux
par ailleurs deux prêtres du diocèse de
paris ont été placés en garde à vue hier
après un montage de vidéos montrant une
procession sans masque lors des fêtes de
pâques en l'église saint-eugène sainte
cécile dans le 9e arrondissement tout
près d'ici à paris est-ce que c'est
justifié ou est-ce que c'est too much
laurent joffrin laurent joffrin petite
précision d'ailleurs selon nos
informations à matignon il ya des
conseillers quand même qu ont déclaré
qu'ils étaient très surpris qu'on sorte
allé jusqu'à mettre en garde à vue les
deux ecclésiastiques hier oui je
comprends que ça puisse choquer mais il
faut que la loi soit la même pour tout
le monde parce qu'on a prononcé des
centaines de milliers d'amande
si on regarde bien souvent c'est pour
des fautes vénielles bon quand vous êtes
fauché ou pas aux très riches en col 135
euros aussi arrosé sur une page je sais
pas il faut combien mille exemples mais
si ensuite il ya des gens plus fortunés
au mieux placés dans la société qui font
la même chose il ya par exemple d'être
plus indulgent au contraire il vaut
mieux que cela il eût fallu que ces gens
là donnent de nas donne l'exemple et
donc que c'est un peu normal de les
sanctionner
je sais me paraît logique ouais moi je
trouve ça moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
l'atmosphère qui règne de sociétés de
non seulement de défiance mais une
société de délation
moi ce qui m'a vraiment choqué dans
dance est la cause de ce crétin de
gérants sont oui mais alors sur l'église
c'est plus grave moi je mangeais
vraiment très personnelle mais je trouve
que cette cérémonie c'était un
diddy personnes qui souhaitent baptisé
qui entrait dans le baptême qui
accédaient de d'entrer dans la foi
catholique alors je crois qu'il est un
musulman juif des athées dont seraient
dues être une grande fête pour le
christianisme qui ment qui manquent de
chrétiens et c'est devenu c'est devenu
une affaire quasiment une affaire d'état
et surtout ses parties du du témoignage
d'un des frères des baptisés c'est à
dire comme acte de charité chrétienne
pour accompagner son frère dans la
maison de dieu on a du mal à trouver
mieux qu'ils envoient une vidéo parisien
donc cette ambiance me désole chalencon
on n'a toujours pas savoir si c'est une
grosse blague complètement stupide parce
que dans les images que j'ai vues moi je
vois pas je vois des gens qui font
semblant enfin je vois pas déjà en train
de dîner je vois des tables découvert
qu'ils sont mis des plats qui sont
disposés des gens debout
je n'arrive pas vraiment à savoir donc
on saura mais à chaque fois on est sûr
de la délation moi dans mon quartier
l'autre jour on a croisé quelqu'un qui
était en train de parler des policiers
en disant j'ai vu chez le voisin terme
ici vraiment l'ambiance de clouzot qu on
alors là je suis d'accord et cette
atmosphère en vis-à-vis je comprends
mais je comprends que la justice
publique selon lui de réagir bien sûr
est justement que mick gens pensent que
mais qu'est ce que cela veut dire si des
gens sortent deux sortes des rails c'est
qu'il ya vraiment une fatigue une non et
art en plus à l'intérieur de l'église
l'idée qu' on est des gens responsables
on est dans une église qui fait 50
mètres de long et 25 mètres de large
ils sont 200 donc il me semble que
l'espace et il est quand même assez
vaste on n'est pas dans un lieu clos
comme l'impression donc on en profite un
peu pour faire du cateau bashing c'est
de bonne guerre mais j'ai l'impression
qu'on prend des ces scènes là je pense
qu'il y en a des dizaines des centaines
dans toute la france que les gens ont
besoin de se dire que la vie ne consiste
pas à passer son temps
encore une fois masquer que les pouvoirs
publics effectivement exercice mais de
là jusqu'à mettre des prêtres en garde à
vue comme de dangereux criminels ayant
mille la vie d'autrui en danger a très
bien à ce moment là on met le directeur
de la ratp en garde à vue parce que -
parfois je suis obligée de prendre la
fin je prends le métro bondé comme tout
le monde par foyer des gens qui n'ont
pas leurs masques elles sont là je vais
me plaindre directement avec les pieds
les directeurs de supermarchés dont les
caissières doit subir des gens qui n'ont
pas la masse on les met pas en garde à
vue donc
il ya quand même une forme de souplesse
à avoir même si encore une fois je
convoque les services publics soient
obligés de faire respecter la loi c'est
leur devoir
je ne suis pas favorable à l'enfermement
les prêtres n'est plus le temps de
l'avent des dénis de la commune
je les mets en revanche en réel et 1.6
jeu qui permet de plus amples cesser
cette idée que les médias ont une part
de responsabilité
pourquoi est ce qu'on attendait qu à une
accusation llopart non il n'y a pas de
lieu et ya pas de date d il ya des
milliers les ministres ça fait ça
remplit les chaînes d'info mais c'est
passé par un journaliste me semble t il
y avait au moins trois questions et qui
quand et où
aurait on ne sait pas qui sait pas quand
on sait pas où et on en discute pendant
dix jours un peu fou qu'on en ferait
mieux de dire bon c'est une bêtise qui a
dit ce personnage et on passe à autre
chose au lieu de remuer la sauce
est-ce que vous attribuez ça justement à
ce que
notre confrère daniel bilalian qui venus
souvent ici attribue à la feuilletons
nisation intrinsèque au chef à la
multiplication des chaînes d'info en
continu un métier beaucoup de jeunes
infos que j'ai pour moi j'y vais tout le
temps contre mais c'est la manière de
parler librement et sans contrainte
vous n'êtes pas sur une chaîne d'infos
là donc à menacer la banale elle va
librement gérait pas je vous rassure
mais simplement oui il a raison
comment il a raison je crois en tes
raisons daniel bilalian en disant que
c'est effectivement le format des infos
qui s'appelait alors on aura joué bien
sûr c'est bien sûr la feuille tonéo qui
obligea feuilletonner bien sûr sur des
sur des événements qui parfois il en
mairie de lacunes d'ailleurs qui souvent
sont dans la presse écrite qui était la
presse sérieuse n'est ce pas ne font que
un écho ou quelques lignes en vo et en
plus la voit bien que ça flatte le côté
poujadiste le des gens donc c'est parce
que dans la presse écrite lorsqu'on
donne une information on essaie quand
même de donner un maximum d'informations
concrets dont elles dont parle laurent
et là on s'aperçoit qu'on n'a pas de nom
qu'on n'a pas de lieu qu'on a des
témoignages qu'il faut recouper qu'on
arrive pas recoupé donc on n'en fait pas
un sujet alors que la chaîne d'info ne
s'arrête pas à ces d'état qui sont
pourtant dans l'ordre du journalisme de
base le problème pour vous si j'ai bien
compris
laurent c'est que ça flatte le côté
poujadiste des gens se sentent bien
flavin 10 salles payant la vindicte
populaire sait pas si c'est le pire le
pire c'est le fait générateur c'est le
dîner illégale dans un endroit un peu
mieux chic comme ça mais si cette idée
de vindicte contre les dirigeants contre
les élites et vous aviez la démagogie à
la fin des fins et vous êtes 4 chalands
sont ces différents mais vous avez dit
raymond important le coton les ministres
là je trouve ça je trouve ça y est ça et
puis et puis l'ambiance et d'un dîner
apparemment de luxe avec des sommes
astronomiques donc en plus ça permet ça
renforce l'idée que d'abord c'est des
puissants qu'ils sont petits trucs qui
font ça en toute impunité et en plus ils
sont riches
donc là on a tous les ingrédients pour
en faire effectivement un feuilleton
critique des élites qui nous gouvernent
et qui est qui nous maintiennent dans
une dictature sanité alors que même le
reste je ne respecte pas les règles
qu'ils ont édicté pour les gueux que
nous sommes
sauf que apparemment va pour l'instant
on n'a pas de nom donc c'est quand même
compliqué d'en faire toute une histoire
il me semble
il ya un certain nombre également
d'internautes qui sont en fin de vie et
qui sont très vindicatif à l'encontre
des
journaliste des plats des journalistes
des prêtres là en l'occurrence on
précisera injuste que l'une des lignes
de défense en tous les cas de
de l'église saint-eugène à paris c'était
de dire qu' il y as en terme entre le
cas de monde il y avait
les jours j'étais à peu à peu près
respectées selon les différentes
informations ce serait plutôt les 50%
il n'y a pas de 30% comme le voudrait la
la jauge c'est vrai que c'est une info
qui est peu cas peut circuler
c'est une église qui fait plus de mille
mètres carrés qui fait 15 mètres de haut
s'est pas tout à fait comme ce studio là
où nous sommes un mètre
quatre-vingt-cinq les uns des autres
masses de mettre deux matches c'est lui
qui perd 2,2 m 2 m 2 mètres comme arme
et 7-6 7/1 c'est un point intéressant
parce que effectivement on a vu
justement beaucoup glosé sur les chaînes
sur les chaînes sur des plateaux avec
des gens qui étaient sans masque alors
il ya des endroits où on peut ne pas
avoir de masques quand on est à plus de
deux mètres les uns des autres est vrai
nom mais lui-même on a vu des images de
mention optique on accuse de ne pas
avoir de masques oui alors qu'il est en
tout seul dans le coeur à 15 mètres des
des fidèles enfin je trouve que cette
affaire on a un peu monté en épingle
pour en profiter pour pointer du doigt
le mais on va bien voir la semaine
prochaine commence le ramadan donc on va
peut-être trouvé des imams qui se
tiennent pas correctement qu'on va
vouloir mettre en garde à vue bien
entendu comme les prêtres n'est pas de
raison j'en doute
cet internaute qui nous dit que dans son
église les églises sont désertes donc il
n'y a pas de problème dans
de son côté le cet autre internaute qui
nous dit il va falloir pousser les murs
des commissariats
le principe de la garde de vue nous dit
un syndicaliste c'est de permettre une
enquête pas punir sans procès et 10 sur
youtube y aura-t-il encore de la place
en cellule pour les vrais criminels et
iris qui estime que ces mesures sont
stupides n'offrent aucun bénéfice sur
celui de nous priver de notre liberté
individuelle sous les maisons c'est
comme le palais vivienne n'est pas très
loin de l'église saint-eugène si ça se
trouve
challans ont été suivis dans la même
cellule par les deux prêtres avaient
plutôt l inverse alors de savoir dans
quelle justement coup est rude et garde
à vue mais c'est encore une info qu'on
recherche c'est dans le commissariat du
9e ou bien au dépôt du tribunal
tg de paille de paris si vous avez
l'info justement on l'apprend faut-il
des gardes à vue pour le non respect des
mesures sanitaires c'est la question
qu'on vous posez sur twitter et la
réponse est non selon vous à 61% vous
êtes un peu moins de 40% à dire oui
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi on
on rappelle que parmi les lectures de ce
vendredi lecture et bien il y a le
figaro magazine
avec donc en une cette alerte lancée par
mathieu bock côté et sonia mabrouk
contre la révolution racialiste en cours
le livre s'appelle la révolution
racialiste de mettre le bock côté et
c'est aux presses de la cité et puis
bien entendu vous n'oubliez pas le
dernier livre sur napoléon 2 jean
christophe buisson et et ce2 le jeu
laurent joffrin j'allais dire j'allais
dire que vous dire que je gardais le
meilleur pour la fin
mais anti macron en tous les cas c'est
de la politique aux éditions c'est pas
sur le sol et hop c'est pas sûr sur
napoléon puisque effectivement c'est pas
vous qui avez fait l'analogie entre
napoléon jean dominique merchet napoléon
et
et bonaparte c'était jean dominique
merchet dans un livre qu'on avait salué
on s'entend et qui fut votre
collaborateur à libération dans le temps
on va se quitter avec les images
justement à devant le palais dans le
château de windsor
les britanniques alors même selon au
mépris parfois des consignes sanitaires
salle aura été et cet après midi 2 et
sont obligés de porter de masse de les
respecter en tous les cas il leur a été
demandé de respecter de ne pas trop
venir pour respecter les consignes
sanitaires apparemment tout le monde ne
respecte pas là non plus cette consigne
et donc on suivra et on continuera de
suivre les derniers les développements
autour de l'hommage rendu au prince
philippe de d'edimbourg qui a qui est
décédé aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'a annoncé
le palais de buckingham
à la mi-journée dans un communiqué à
très vite
excellent week-end sur figaro
[Musique]